la parole est à notre collègue daniel
l'euro pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ma question portera sur les zones de non
traitement comme le dit notre président
gérard larcher
les maires sont apportés d'engueulades
alors pour peu qu'il soit agriculteur
c'est la double peine
les agriculteurs sont les noms et
nouveaux boucs émissaires un suicide
tous les deux jours ce n'est plus
tolérable
la profession n'a pas attendu pour
travailler à l'élaboration de chartes
d'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires à proximité des
habitations ou à s'organiser dans une
démarche de responsabilité
environnementale
les agriculteurs connaissent les
produits qu'ils utilisent ils ne vont
pas traiter les jours où les enfants
sont présents dans les écoles où le
dimanche à midi lorsque les familles des
jeunes sur la terrasse ce sont des
règles de bon sens la mise en place de
zones de non traitement doit nous
interpeller sur le principe même un
produit dangereux à 3 m
le sera tout autant à 10 ou à 150 est ce
la distance ou la dangerosité du produit
la source du problème la réduction
d'utilisation à la sortie des pesticides
sont des enjeux environnementaux
économiques et sociaux importants pour
l'avenir mais qui autorise la mise sur
le marché
ce ne sont pas les agriculteurs que l'on
propose enfin des produits de
substitution avec une innocuité verrait
et une harmonisation européenne les et
netteté concerne à la fois l'agriculture
conventionnelle et biologique
je constate certaines incohérences
comment atteindre les objectifs de
surface 1 école agriculture biologique
si on supprime la possibilité d'utiliser
les produits homologués bio tels que le
cuivre par exemple monsieur le ministre
de l'agriculture l'a justement indiqué
dnt à plus de 100 mètres c'est notre
autonomie alimentaire qui seraient mises
à mal avec plus de 20 % de surfaces
agricoles amputés et l'obligation de se
fournir sur le marché mondial avec des
garanties sanitaires et
environnementales moindre vous avez
lancé une consultation
gageons que le dialogue et la
concertation dans nos territoires
l'emporteront monsieur le premier
ministre nous attend dans votre réponse
merci pour vos réponses
la parole est à m